hey guys dr. Berg here in this short
video we're going to talk about the
secret to fixing low testosterone okay
now you ready for the secret are you
ready for this
are you sitting now so it's not about
necessarily trying to boost your
testosterone that's not it
out of all the things that you can do
it's really the avoidance of something
that will improve testosterone and so
first thing we're talking about is the
symptoms and then I'm going to get into
the things that you can do to boost it
but then I'm going to talk about that
three things you need to pay attention
to to avoid so you can really get your
testosterone back okay so first of all
let's talk about the symptoms decreased
libido decrease erections decreased
vitality you're starting to gain some
weight around the midsection and you
cannot build muscle mass so you go work
out the muscle is not coming back or not
getting bigger okay that's all signs of
deficiency and testosterone and what's
interesting is you get older in your 40s
and 50s and 60s testosterone starts
going down down down down down okay in a
female body it goes up so everything is
reversed right so now let's talk about
the triggers so it is true yeah you can
take Vinc from seafood and beef and lamb
and sesame seeds and pumpkin seeds you
can do that okay and you can take
vitamin D and vitamin D actually is from
the Sun or you can do take it from cod
liver oil and the only vegetarian
vegetation a vegetarian source would be
mushrooms and then vitamin A from cod
liver oil and then resisted exercise all
those are really good to trigger
testosterone but it doesn't make a huge
impact as compared to avoiding these
three things I'm going to talk about
next okay so there are three hormones
that in the presence of these hormones
testosterone is going to plummet okay
number one is insulin
okay this regulates blood sugars number
two estrogen when estrogen goes up
testosterone goes down and three is
cortisol when cortisol goes up
testosterone goes down alright
so out of these three
yes insulin will do it cortisol will do
it but the most important thing that you
need to focus on is your estrogen levels
because if that estrogen is too high and
it's very very common because as you get
older especially in a male body the
estrogen goes up and your testosterone
goes down so you notice your voice
starts getting higher the skin starts
getting thinner and softer
that's estrogen okay so real quick I put
some links down below of how to fix like
if you have problems with insulin
resistance and what to avoid with that
you know definitely in a minute fasting
and cutting out sugars and things so
that's I don't want to put a tension on
that because I want to focus more on the
estrogens but you want to handle the
insulin and then cortisol cortisol is
all about getting rid of stress and hand
in hint enhancing your sleep and getting
to you're getting a good adrenal gland
function okay so now let's just put some
attention on this estrogen now the
single biggest source of hidden estrogen
in in your diet is basically from
consuming animal products not because
the animals are injected with estrogen
it's because this animal feed
so they give them soy unless it's
grass-fed they're giving a grain and now
it's kind of laughs when you see on the
label it's like oh yeah this uh these
eggs or our vegetarian fed all that
means is we're giving them soy and corn
okay both of them are GMO so not only
does that increase estrogen because you
have it's filled with pesticides like
you know herbicides and Roundup Ready
but the biggest thing is the soy feed
that's fed to the chickens and the
cattle that's the thing that's messing
people up so there's even an
organization now that's trying to
monitor that but if they haven't really
got too far because it's very political
but if you're going to consume animal
products is better be grass-fed and
definitely organic because this is
estrogen effect and so also if you have
some extra fat in your body right now
there's an enzyme called aroma taste
that basically is
in your fat and that's converting the
last bit of testosterone you have to
estrogen so your own body is making more
estrogen not to mention the animal
products and everything else so I want
to give you some things to do to
actually clean up the estrogen this
whole estrogen problem is really in the
liver so we want to make sure the liver
is really really good so there's the top
foods that you should be eating right
now to lower your estrogen and their
anti estrogen ik and they will also
inhibit this enzyme our cruciferous
vegetables and you probably heard that
before
kale broccoli Brussels sprouts and do a
shake of kale beet leaves and parsley
because parsley is a really good anti
estrogenic vegetable as well so you do
that olive oil is very anti extra genic
celery is very anti estrogenic mushrooms
have a very high anta estrogenic just
regular those little button mushrooms
you can just start consuming those women
in a study with women that consumed I
think was like eight ounces of mushrooms
they decrease their breast cancer by 50%
so it's pretty significant so we want to
start changing the diet and start to
improve in the liver the other thing
that will increase the estrogen in
addition to the animal feeds and is any
type of soy in the diet
soy protein isolates I mean soils in so
many foods it's just very very
estrogenic and 95 percent of it is GMO
the last thing i want to talk about is
another hidden source of estrogen is
alcohol
okay alcohol it's very estrogenic too
and and the problem with men is they
start getting man boobs they start
getting prostate problems because of the
estrogen effect okay so I just wanted to
put your attention on the most important
thing to put your attention on if you
have low tea it's this little guy right
here start cleaning up the liver start
adding more vegetables to start getting
this estrogen out change your diet go to
grass-fed and thank you so much for
watching
you